hey hola antes de hablar de la forma
vectorial de la aproximación cuadrática
de funciones de varias variables tenemos
que hablar de la matriz es jana vamos a
hablar de la matriz hetian a tiana muy
bien que esencialmente es una forma de
empaquetar toda la información de las
segundas derivadas parciales de nuestra
función entonces si nosotros partimos de
una función fx que digamos la función
del vídeo anterior que era a la equis
medios por el seno de iu entonces la la
forma de calcular la matriz que es jana
es muy fácil generalmente algunos libros
la denotan como con una h como como en
negrita es verdad generalmente por la
tipografía verdad y esto será una matriz
que contenga todas las derivadas
parciales de segundo orden de nuestra
función f entonces partimos digamos de
la de la segunda derivada de f con
respecto de x
ambas veces y de hecho en esta columna
siempre vamos a derivar con respecto de
equis y luego con respecto a la
siguiente variable verdad siempre será
digamos en ese orden ahora vamos a
derivar primero con respecto de y para
esta columna y luego vamos a derivar
respecto de equis y luego respecto de
para la última entrada entonces primero
aquí derivamos con respecto de x como
siempre en esta columna primero respecto
de iu y luego respecto a la siguiente
variable que es otra vez y entonces
derivamos dos veces con respecto de ye
para esta entrada y esta es la matriz
genciana de nuestra función
efe muy bien entonces para poder
calcular la necesitamos primero la
información de las primeras derivadas
parciales muy bien entonces tendremos
que calcular la derivada de f con
respecto de x quien es la derivada con
respecto de x bueno en realidad éste es
el único término que depende de x así
que lo derivamos y nos da un medio
a la equis medios y luego multiplicamos
por la constante para fines de derivar
con respecto de x que es seno de y ahora
bien si derivamos con respecto de y
entonces el término que tiene ya es esto
el seno de iu entonces lo demás es
constante que da a la equis medios por
la derivada del seno de iu que es coseno
de g
muy bien entonces éstas por supuesto no
van a ir en nuestra matriz que sean a
pero son útiles para poder calcular las
segundas derivadas verdad entonces aquí
vamos a tener que nuestra matriz será
derivar respecto de x la derivada
respecto de x entonces si derivamos esto
aquí vemos que esto es el único término
o el único factor que depende de x será
un cuarto verdad aquí tenemos un medio
sale otro medio se hace un cuarto y a la
equis medios por el seno de iu y ahora
calculamos éste esta misma derivada
ahora la derivamos con respecto de iu y
éste es el único término que depende de
verdad entonces
la segunda derivada de esto digamos la
entrada que va aquí sería derivar esto
respecto de jay sería un medio a la
equis medios por la derivada del seno de
ley que es co seno de iu muy bien
tenemos nuestra primera columna y aquí
nosotros ya sabemos que en realidad va a
ser lo mismo porque estamos calculando
las derivadas cruzadas pero bueno vamos
a convencernos de que en realidad valen
lo mismo entonces tenemos primero la
derivada de respecto de iu y la
derivamos respecto de x entonces al
derivar esto respecto de x tendremos un
medio a la x medios por el coseno de
yeyé entonces no es sorprendente verdad
que en realidad las derivadas cruzadas
coincidan aunque por supuesto existen
algunas funciones para las cuales estas
derivadas cruzadas no son simétricas es
decir si pueden tomar valores distintos
ok pero pero bueno esta es una de esas
funciones típicas para las cuales sí
coinciden verdad y ahora sólo nos falta
derivar esta con respecto de y entonces
otra vez
este es el 1
término que depende de tendremos a la
equis medios por la derivada del coseno
de ye que es menos el seno de iu bien
entonces esta es la matriz cristiana
para esta función particular así que
esta matriz donde cada entrada es una
función multi variable es la matriz
gestiona ya veces a esta matriz se le
indica de qué funciones estamos hablando
aquí se indica como un subíndice la
función de la cual estamos obteniendo
esta matriz es jana muy bien entonces
podríamos pensar en realidad de esta
matriz como como si fuera una función
con valores matricial es verdad para
cada equis que obtenemos una matriz que
cada entrada depende de x
muy bien entonces lo bonito de esta
función perdón más bien de esta matriz
es que podemos extender esta idea cuando
tenemos por ejemplo al caso en donde
tengamos muchas más variables entonces
por ejemplo pensemos que esta función
f no depende de xy de y sino que depende
de tres variables digamos pensemos que
depende de x y y ceta muy bien esta
función digamos que depende de x y y
ceta entonces si así fuera como
calculamos ahora su matriz es jana bueno
pues esencialmente tendríamos que
extender esta matriz verdad para
calcular todas las derivadas parciales
boots vamos a dejar lo que si nos sirve
vamos a dejar esto
y borremos de una vez esta en realidad
esto sólo sirvió para nuestro ejemplo
muy bien entonces recordemos cómo se
calcula el primer renglón perdón la
primera columna verdad la primera
columna siempre consiste en derivar
primero con respecto de xy luego sería
derivar con respecto de x derivar con
respecto de jay y aquí sería derivar con
respecto de c está muy bien entonces así
estaría ahora como calculamos nuestra
segunda columna primero derivamos
respecto de y verdad siempre derivamos
primero respecto de yale luego aquí
sería respecto de x respecto de ye lo
cual nos da la segunda derivada de f
respecto de ambas veces y finalmente
derivamos con respecto de z entonces
para la tercera columna recordemos ahora
vamos a derivar primero respecto de z y
luego en este caso respecto de x
respecto de z y para este renglón sería
respecto de iu y para esta última
entrada tendremos la derivada respecto
de z y luego respecto de z verdad
entonces sería respecto de z ambas veces
entonces esta es la matriz hetian a para
una función con tres variables y aquí se
ve cómo extender digamos este patrón que
hemos desarrollado en los dos ejemplos
verdad a cuando tengamos más variables y
por ejemplo hubiera cuatro variables
entonces la matriz cristiana sería de 4
x 4 si tuviéramos 100 variables
tendríamos de una matriz de 100% verdad
entonces aquí aquí lo bonito de todo
esto es que podemos hablar de la matriz
simplemente utilizando este símbolo
verdad hf y veremos en los próximos
vídeos como ayuda a expresar digamos la
la aproximación cuadrática de cualquier
función de varias variables no sólo de
dos variables como hemos visto hasta
ahora y de hecho no nos vamos a
amontonar entre tanto símbolo de
derivadas parciales y demás
porque en realidad no habrá una
necesidad de hacer referencia a cada una
de las entradas de la matriz cristiana
sólo necesitaremos hacer algunas
operaciones con matrices y vectores
bueno nos vemos en el próximo vídeo